russia's war of persuasion starts at
home fireworks
and russian flags in the region now
recognized as not ukraine the
pro-russian accounts on state television
and justification from president putin
himself that ukraine isn't a real
country
modern ukraine was entirely created by
russia says putin an integral part of
our history historical ties go back
centuries cultural economic religious
political putin's version allows
ukraine's national boundaries to be
erased rationalized in part by the
russian ethnicity of many people in
ukraine he doesn't
see ukraine as being a separate nation
from russia ethnically ukraine is 78
ukrainian and just 17 russian but in
donetsk and luhansk deemed independent
by moscow the russian ethnic makeup is
almost 40 percent and crimea already
taken by russia close to 60 percent
that's one of his arguments
that the eastern part of ukraine has
more uh russian speakers then what does
it mean for countries like latvia 26 of
the population has russian ethnicity
more than ukraine and estonia 25 are
russian by background but those
countries have membership in nato a
protection that ukraine does not have
there is a difference of course of being
nato member and not being nato member as
ukraine shows ukraine is surrounded by
russian might and while putin's vision
may sell to many russians to most of the
world ukrainians are not russians
this is our land said president
zielinski we will not give anything to
anybody
it seems extremely costly to invade
ukraine
in a major way lisa sunstrom thinks
putin is likely to destabilize the
ukrainian government rather than
overthrow it but putin's rhetoric
suggests russia's historical destiny is
at stake putin is trying to re-establish
as much as is feasible for russia
control over areas of former soviet
territory however putin views russia's
historic entitlement a broader invasion
of ukraine would spark a terrible
conflict and it's not clear even
patriotic russians want that eric
sorensen global news toronto